je trouvais plus mes baskets et je vois
lui et bentalha qui se marrent qui se
marque ne crois pas j'y vais doucement
ce que je me dis me prépare un coup et
quand j'arrive je retrouve mes baskets
dans lequel cyril a fait ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
matin
et
merci et en direct sur scène et vous lis
sahara ça traite à travers ses dessins
animés de plein de problèmes de société
et c'est ça qui est très fort bravo en
tout cas franck vous êtes excellent
encore dedans vous savez que je vous
aime parce que vous êtes mon âme et
aussi parce que vous êtes un excellent
acteur
merci excellent réalisateur j'ai une
petite surprise groupe à ce que je vous
ai offert des chaussures voilà je vous
ai offert des baskets hier fait
longtemps que je veux lui offrir des
baskets et j'ai une autre mais pourquoi
mais non mais c'est bon on va pas dire
pourquoi maintenant qu'on sait pas
pourquoi j'aurais une raison à ça ce
cadre et parce que il fait pas de cadeau
pour rien le mec vous le savez tous ce
truc là c'est un beau cadeau à celle de
la jordan c'est une très belle paire
merci beaucoup mais c'est pour se faire
pardonner d'une d'une usine est d'une
bêtise d'une bombe à ces bons est ce
qu'il ya des fois il ya des choses qui
vous sont arrivés à vous dans l'équipe
et les des gens disent c'est vrai qu'il
fait ça de notre gamme très grave s'il
fait ça mais en fait il fait 50 items
beaucoup et alors cet été je trouvais
plus mes baskets et je vois lui et
bentalha qui se marrent qui se marre je
ne crois pas j'y vais doucement ce que
je me dis me prépare un coup et quand
j'arrive je retrouve mes baskets dans
lequel cyril a fait ses besoins et vous
dire la vérité on a passé l'été avec lui
il était tout le temps au téléphone à la
fin avec malik bentalha on en avait
marre on a dit ben voilà on va lui
donner une leçon
dans un instant il y aura ces mots et
franck tous les soirs je fais une petite
surprise parfois à mes invités ou à
quelqu'un du public et ce soir c'est toi
qui est ce que la transition est due à
la 3e' l'union avant de devenir comédien
réalisateur scénariste série qu au tout
hollywood te veux maintenant qui
dressait des caniches des chihuahuas des
pitbulls ans mais c'est vrai très tôt tu
commences à réaliser des documentaires
sur le dressage de chiens regarde on
voit lui sa caméra et son chien lie
hébreu live et en 2000 qu'approcher pour
travailler en tongs dresseur canin sur
le film les rivières pourpres su
sympathise avec mathieu kassovitz qui va
être très important pour toi on embrasse
d'ailleurs mathieu kassovitz et nous
regarde et on le voit en photo avec
l'excellent vincent cassel donc là voilà
et c'est à cette période que tu
rencontres une personne qui va beaucoup
compter pour thau affrontent cet ami
devenu très très proches au fil du temps
va également aider surgénération
molosses est ce que tu vois de qui je
veux parler
avec tous ces indices est ce que tu
penses une personne en particulier
si je te dis ludovic way est ce que ça
t'évoque quelque chose regarde
ludovic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors avec mon bateau je n'ai pas vu non
je te suis faso sa question
non je ne suis pas c
on avait une photo de vacances de vous
et non mais arrêtez
sans déconner non non non mais tu
connais ludovic non bien sûr que non
ludovic si et quand par exemple
ben en 2003 quand j'ai quand j'étais
avec toi sur le sur l'ordre voulait
dormir à la maison à la rue de la
roquette sur mon clic-clac non non tout
est faux pour parents travaux est ce que
vous connaissez cette personne n'a envie
sûr que là il est venu me dire pendant
la pub montre à nos galères le bon mais
qui peuvent amener au maire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a voulu piéger franck gastambide et
lui permet un mec génie tu joue le jeu
et n'a pas du tout joué les autres
marionnettes un chien je t'aime quand
même prendre ensemble ils contrôlent
gaza d'un solide n'importe quoi
[Musique]